this week we're talking about bigquery
anomaly detection and data engineering
I'm Cassie kozakov and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news bigquery already
lets you analyze petabytes of data at
lightning speed and it just got even
better with the addition of a bunch of
cool new features including new
user-defined functions faster reporting
capabilities increased concurrency
limits and new functions for encryption
and GIS the bottom line
helping you get more out of your data
faster see the article for tutorials and
demo links last year we announced
bigquery ml bringing supervised machine
learning to your multi petabyte dataset
and now we've added unsupervised
learning capabilities to in this blog
post you'll learn how to train a machine
learning model to catch the prizes in
your data all without having to write a
single line of code outside of bigquery
sequel check out the full story and
while we're on the topic of sequel let's
talk about database migration if you're
keen to migrate your my sequel database
to cloud sequel our fully managed
database service designed to take care
of that heavy lifting for you
you might want to check out this new
hands-on tutorial for setting up your
automated migration workflow for the
data engineers among you we're excited
to announce a professional data engineer
certification exam to put that spotlight
on your expertise go earn your
certificate today and get noticed faster
for high demand roles if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link have
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you